I'm so happy I'm here to be able to get
to talk about a viral maths problem I
mean when does that happen
come on and this is not in the map
community we're talking about like in
the big wide world this is really
exciting have you heard of it Brady it's
got a few names at the moment it's like
with a Singapore maths problem I could
say it's a company competition maths
problem originating from Singapore it's
also the Sherrill problem and not saying
anything against Sheryl Cheryl's not a
problem Cheryl's usually a pretty nice
so if you've been living under a rock
I'll quickly explain what it is it's
actually from a mathematical point of
view it's a classic logic problem it
involves three people Cheryl Albert and
Bernard okay so Cheryl is trying to get
Albert and Bernard to guess her birthday
for what reason we don't know you know
maybe she's just trying to play out but
against Bernhard or maybe I would have
Bernard you know trying to scam Cheryl
for like her secret question for a bank
account who knows but anyway she gives
them a bunch of options
okay so Cheryl has shared a possible
pool of dates but now what she's done is
she's actually going to give a piece of
information to Albert and a piece of
information to burn it an incomplete
piece of information about her birthday
so this is what this is how it goes it
goes Albert I'm going to tell you the
month okay and Bernard I'm going to tell
you the date it's always boys bub
okay so now they have they all they know
is is that Bernard knows that Albert
knows the month and Albert knows that
Bernhard knows the date but they don't
know it together okay and so then they
have a little exchange
so Albert states I don't know when
Cheryl's birthday is , but I know that
Bernard does not know - then Bernard
replies at first I didn't know when
Cheryl's birthday is but I know now so
now suddenly Bernhard knows but what
happens is Albert left in the dark no
somehow Albert is then able to deduce
then I also know when Cheryl's birthday
is so now they both know
and presumably cherylin showing was
either happy or upset or a bank account
or a bank account has been broken into
something like that we don't know
exactly the question is how can you find
out the information nothing is explicit
is it Brady
I mean it just seems like they're
playing games I mean they Jedi's what's
going on and they're reading each
other's minds and this is the nature of
these logic problems believe it or not
this isn't the first time I've been
faced with a problem like this as
mathematicians we get asked these
problems all the time and so the way to
answer this is to actually break it down
and try and attack it logically because
otherwise you're not going to get
anywhere I am now going to rearrange
this information here because this is
really important we need to have
something to focus on so what I'm going
to do is I'm actually going to split out
the dates so at the top here I'm going
to I'm going to put 1415 but the dates
there in columns and in rows I'm going
to place the months so here is May 2 now
what I'm going to do there is I'm just
going to have a look at it so May 15
okay our crosses just basically this is
an option this could be it 16 or 19 yeah
these are these are all contenders what
I'm going to do is actually give us a
bit of understanding here because once
we get into the logic we could get lost
let's look at the options for this
column for the the day or the date 14
how many different options do we have
we've got two okay fifteen we have two
16 we have two 17 we have two 18 we have
one and 19 we have one as well
okay now let's have a look for months so
now for months how many options do we
have for each month so we have 1 2 3 4
may 2 for June 2 for July and 3 for
August see where I'm going with this
Brady so now what's going on here is
that I've actually just I've just spread
out the information before I start
bringing in the weird conversation that
they had the weird tourist conversation
that they had so now Albert says I don't
know I don't know what the birth
okay of course he doesn't yeah but
that's a weird thing to say can I just
say that it is a weird thing to say
because in a logic problem
obviously you don't we both know the
game here you've only been told months
there is three options two options two
options three options the only way you'd
know is if there was one month there
with only one date okay just saying that
I'm just saying that what's interesting
though is Albert says but I also know
that Bernhard doesn't know how could he
know that we've got the information in a
way that you know I'm going to be able
to work with but just looking at this
straight away there are some red hot
dates here June 18 well if you have a
look at it it's only 118 that applies to
any of the months it happens to be June
an actual fact the same for May there's
19 19 is not anywhere else can you see
that bready there's nothing around there
what this means is if Cheryl leant over
and said to Bernard or what that means
is straightaway bernhard would be in
it's like a gimme it's like bang i know
exactly what it is you give me the
information it can only be one thing but
see Albert it's sort of like a gloating
way I mean really Albert needs a little
bit of emotional intelligence I think
because he's basically gloating and he's
going I've got information that excludes
the gimmies so I know Berner that you
don't have guineas for how can he not
know because he doesn't have the date
information he's only got month
information okay what are the months
that had potential for gimmies well they
were June and they were May and that's
the only information that Albert has he
only has month information monthly
information so what can we deduce from
this let's get mathematicians here okay
we're all getting mathematical Albert
says I don't know the date yes okay
that's a weird thing to say but I also
know that Berner does another day so
logically what you've got to say is
therefore Cheryl didn't whisper May or
June in his ear
so obviously Cheryl whispered something
like July or
that's what she did because if she said
May or June
Albert wouldn't be saying that with
conviction well that means that this is
no longer an option and this is no
longer an option
but because Albert has said I know that
18 and 19 are not an option the only way
Albert would have known that is through
monthly information so an actual fact
this is gone this is gone and this is
gone basically everything in May and
everything in June is gone this is great
because with my prize little chart here
I can actually reduce some numbers here
so now this goes down to zero this goes
down to zero so now Bernhard actually
knows all natural fact because all of
May and all of June all the dates that
we had on the table are all gone that
affects the total number of options I
have for each day doesn't matter about
his date he's actually just looking at
all the dates so now for 14 well there's
still two there that hasn't changed but
for 15 we've just struck out May so now
this is only one option for the
sixteenth that was in May and July made
struck out so now there's only one
standing in this column for 17 same
thing look at this there's June 17 and
then as August 17 so this one's gets
struck out and then for 18 and 19 they
turned down to 0-2 so Albert's given
this information now bernhard has been
able to reduce the options but to be
clear for bernhard to know the birthday
he already has the date he just needs
the month so now Bernard says at first I
don't know when Cheryl's birthday is but
I know now so from what Albert has said
Vernon is now able to say what the month
is okay so now let's put ourselves in
Bernhard's shoes so now he is actually
discounted May and June he's reduced the
number of options really you're only
talking about July and August now if he
did have 14
right there are still two options on the
table so he didn't have 14 if he did
have 14 he would have said something
like yeah still don't know okay but
instead he goes I didn't know before
which means he didn't have the gimmies
but now he knows how does he know
because there are actually new gimmies
on the table Brady you wouldn't believe
it look at this the new gimmies are 15
16 and 17
so now if he's holding on to 15 16 or 17
in his in his head or really in his
heart because we're dealing with Cheryl
here what's happening here is he's going
wow there's only one 15 that applies to
August there's only one 16 that applies
to July and there's only one 17 that
applies to August again look if I have
any of these dates I will know exactly
which month it applies to so at this
stage of the problem it could have been
15 16 or 17 so now Bernard is going up
to pop and this one goes down to zero
but not only that because July and
August have now lost a date so that
means over here we need to go
bang-bang-bang
1 and over here we need to go bang bang
bang - right so what's the last
statement Albert says then I also know
when Cheryl's birthday is okay so that
means he's going to give me so now if we
have a look where the gimmies are let's
look at the options he's either got July
or August what options do we have here
well autist is no good because it's got
two options
that means it's ambiguous it means he
doesn't have gimmies it could be either
15 or 17 but because he knows it has to
be July generally that means spreading
it means that albert is going oh sorry
and Albert's going huh sorry
so this now goes down to zero this goes
down here well Albert's doing it so I'm
doing in blue that one goes down to zero
too so now look what we end up with we
end up with one option for the month and
one option
for the date that they can both get and
that option is July 16
okay what's really interesting about
this problem is the fact that because
it's using words it's actually open to
interpretation
if this was actually redone in just pure
symbolic logic it would be unambiguous
but because we're using these sentences
in actual fact people have opened them
up into interpretation